[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
das ist heute abend die hauptstadt der
ukraine knapp drei millionen einwohner
wird angegriffen die menschen im ganzen
land versuchen sich in sicherheit zu
bringen in den schächten der metro wer
irgendwie kann flieht und merkt auch das
geht nicht mehr riesige staus auf den
ausfallstraßen zwingen die leute ihre
autos stehenzulassen und sich zu fuß
durch zu schlagen kleine kinder ganze
familie begonnen hat dieser tag mit
einer kriegserklärung aus moskau
ich habe die entscheidung für eine
militär operation getroffen wie auch
immer versucht uns zu stoppen oder unser
land bedroht der sollte wissen dass
russlands antwort schnell sein wird und
konsequenzen hat solche die es in der
geschichte so noch nie gab
er hat es getan wladimir putin greift
die ukraine an zu land zu wasser aus der
luft seine armee marschiert bei den
nachbarn ein in einer weise wie es nur
pessimisten für möglich gehalten hätten
realisten muss man heute wohl sagen
guten abend hinein es ist kein guter
abend es ist der moment an dem
grundlegende gewissheiten ins wanken
geraten dass es einen solchen krieg in
europa nicht mehr geben würde dass wir
hier die friedens generationen sind auf
eine aggression aus vergangen geglaubten
zeiten muss europa jetzt dringend eine
aktuelle antwort finden die auch die
zukunft sichert auch darüber berichten
wir ausführlich in den kommenden etwa 50
minuten zuerst die lage für die menschen
in der ukraine
christian kirsch
am ersten tag des russischen
angriffskrieges mischen sich
detonationsgeräusche der bomben
mit ungläubigem staunen
mein gott ruft ein ukrainer das schlägt
bei uns ein bei uns und auch hier auf
einem flugplatz in der west ukraine
vierundzwanzigster februar
2022 dieser tag markiert eine wende
luftalarm über kiew
obwohl russland erklärt nur militärische
ziele anzugreifen explodierte eine
granate im süden der ukrainischen
hauptstadt auch hier
ungläubiges staunen handy fotos vom
ersten tag dieses krieges
ich bin sehr sehr nervös sagt sie ich
habe angst aber ich muss stark sein
schutz vor luftangriffen das bedeutet in
der drei millionen stadt kiew vor allem
flucht in die u bahn schächte
der krieg hat angefangen sagte er
nüchtern und
er fürchte vor allem um seinen kleinen
jungen
flächendeckend griff russland heute die
ukrainische luftabwehr an wie hier im
süden nahm mario pohl am abend hieß es
aus moskau man habe auch einige ziele
erreicht
nicht in panik verfallen verlangte der
ukrainische regierungschef von seiner
bevölkerung man sei stark auf alles
vorbereitet und man werde sie
gleich von vier saiten griffen
anschließend russische bodentruppen an
offenbar auch von belarus aus
angriffe auch aus dem separatisten
gebiet und von süden her von der
halbinsel krim
russlands armee dringt immer weiter in
die ukraine vor schier endlos die
kolonnen in der reserve
das nur militärische ziele angegriffen
würden widerlegen diese bilder eines
beschossenen wohnhauses verlässliche
angaben über zivile opfer oder die zahl
der getöteten soldaten gibt es bislang
nicht
am abend hieß es nach heftigen kämpfen
hätten russische truppen das gebiet um
den zerstörten atomreaktor tschernobyl
eingenommen
die lufthoheit über die ukraine scheint
russland erobert zu haben
hubschrauber über der ukrainischen
hauptstadt aus der immer mehr menschen
zu flüchten versuchen sah es hier am
bahnhof oder über die völlig verstopften
ausfallstraßen nur weg aus kiew und
manche sagen nur weg aus der ukraine ein
grenzübergang nach polen hier kamen den
ganzen tag über menschen an auf der
flucht mit kindern und koffern der
anfang einer fluchtwelle an diesem
furchtbaren
vierundzwanzigster februar
bringen wir unsere korrespondentin mit
dazu zunächst katrin eigendorf 260
kilometer südwestlich von kiew kathrin
wie sehr hat die ukrainische regierung
die lage aktuell noch im griff
nun sie vermittelt zumindest den
eindruck dass die lage im griff hat
präsident selensky hat er den ganzen tag
über immer wieder ansprachen an die
bevölkerung gehalten mittlerweile
scheint es so ist er fast heiser ruft
dazu auf ruhig zu bleiben widerstand zu
leisten
man hat den gleichen eindruck auch von
einigen der bürgermeister also ihr der
bürgermeister von hf ähnlich versucht
organisiert zu wirken auch klitschko der
bürgermeister von kiew hat die
bevölkerung dazu aufgerufen ruhe zu
bewahren das ist im moment der eindruck
den die regierung nach außen vermittelt
allerdings können wir das noch nicht
wirklich überprüfen inwieweit sie die
lage im griff hat es gibt auch kritik
dass einige zum beispiel im osten der
ukraine in kharkiv sagen die russen
haben hier längst die kontrolle
übernommen das stimmt nicht aber darüber
können wir uns hier kein umfassendes
bild machen katrin vielen dank weiter zu
für begann nach moskau führte in
mindestens 52 russischen städten gab zum
teil gibt es heute proteste gegen den
krieg es wurden aber hunderte
festgenommen sankt petersburg soll es
vergleichsweise große proteste gegeben
haben kann man sagen wie der russische
angriff bei den menschen in diesem
riesigen land ankommt
trotz der bilder dieser protest ist es
eben so dass ein unabhängiges
meinungsforschungsinstitut heute
herausgefunden hat dass 60 prozent der
russinnen und russen glauben dass die
verursacher dieses krieges die nato und
der westen sind dh dass die erzählung
von putin und seinen staatsmedien hier
eben verfängt dass es viele menschen
gibt die glauben dass die
militäroffensive eine notwendigkeit ist
dass russland etwas zu verteidigen habe
sei es die russisch stämmigen menschen
im donbass oder gleich ganz russland vor
einem aggressiv handelnden westen diese
demonstrationen die heute stattgefunden
haben die mögen zahlenmäßig vielleicht
klein erscheinen ein paar tausend
demonstrationen in millionenstädte
andererseits wenn man sich überlegt wie
gefährlich demonstrieren hier ist wie
viele festnahmen immer dann gibt wenn
menschen sich öffentlich gegen putins
weg äußern dann scheinen die demos in
einem anderen licht für begaben ausbau
herzlichen dank diese informationen
heute abend
roman shell ist freier autor und jetzt
gerade für dreharbeiten im osten der
ukraine unterwegs gewesen muss man sagen
weil er jetzt auf der flucht richtung
westen ist gut herr schell können sie
uns kurz die situation beschreiben in
der sie jetzt aktuell stecken
genannt ich bin ins nahe der stadt nie
büro wurden untergebracht in einem
sanatorium
das gebäude wird nicht daher jetzt es
ist ziemlich kalt hier aber immerhin
haben wir ein dach über dem kopf ich bin
unterwegs mit zehn jugendlichen und
kindern von der ostukrainischen front
werden sie mitgenommen ich bin mir dann
muss sich logan tief hier unterwegs
diese leute haben die kinder und
jugendlichen an der kontakt nieder in
der ost ukraine therapiert und das dorf
aus dem die kinder kommen war besonders
heftig wurde besonders heftig geschossen
in den letzten tagen motivierte haben
uns angetreten mitzunehmen das haben wir
gemacht geht es den bp verantwortlich
und jetzt dringen wird die kinder
richtung polnische grenze ich nehme an
die eltern haben sie zurückgelassen oder
zurücklassen müssen
was haben sie gemacht und die die kinder
machen sich ganz ganz große sorgen um
die eltern um die omas und opas sie
telefonieren andauernd miteinander und
es gibt es gibt schlechte nachrichten
aus dem dorf von der kontakt linie
ihr dorf wird weiterhin beschossen und
alle menschen hausen schon seit zwei
tagen in kellern herrscher können sie
uns beschreiben wie sie diesen tag
erlebt haben sie sind seit heute morgen
um 5 uhr unterwegs
genau wie wir alle menschen die aktiv
bin ich aus dem schlaf gerissen worden
weil die stadt und da bestimmt beschluss
stand ganz plötzlich habe ich es das
donnern der hatte gehört wahrscheinlich
war das war keine arte die rede waren
russische raketen
ich habe dann schnell sachen gepackt
bienen zu den kindern gefahren zwischen
uns waren wahrscheinlich sein kilometer
oder anderthalb kilometer wenn sie mir
gleich sieben uhr morgens ausgebrochen
sollten schnell wegfahren aber die
ganzen straßenbahn verstaubt
sind wir sind wir sind wahrscheinlich
sieben oder acht stunden unterwegs
gewesen oder ohne 9
und sind nur 200 kilometer gefahren weil
weil weil über über all den stars ganz
ukraine scheint so zu sein ist bewegung
ganz ukraine fährt richtung besten weg
vor den russischen truppen aber auch der
westen der ukraine wird immer wenn bei
dir ich weiß nicht wo die menschen
sicherer sind dass wir jetzt meine frage
an sie haben sie in irgendeiner form
optionen jetzt irgendeine idee einen
plan für morgen wie sie sich und die
kinder in sicherheit bringen könnten
unser plan für morgen sind folgen aus
ich bin mit profis unterwegs ist 40
aktivisten den aktivisten unterwegs wie
schon seit acht jahren kinder und
jugendliche therapieren sie kennen sich
gut aus das sind leute aus der ukraine
leben lang straßen gemeinden
militärstützpunkte wir sind wir können
nicht genau wissen wo das gebäude sind
ja wir hoffen dass wir morgen nicht
unter beschuss geraten wo mancher freier
autor zurzeit unterwegs in der ukraine
auf der flucht herzlichen dank für das
gespräch herr
land
und dann guckt muss jetzt die aktuelle
lage mal auf einer karte ein bisschen
genauer an das ist die streitmacht der
sich die ukraine gegenüber sieht knapp
180.000 soldaten seit heute morgen
dringend diese russischen truppen aus
mehreren aufmarsch gebieten in die
ukraine ein von norden her etwa auf die
hauptstadt kiew zu das gebiet um
tschernobyl soll bereits in russischer
hand sein und wir haben meldungen das in
fast allen teilen der ukraine also auch
weit im westen offenbar vor allem
flughäfen und flugabwehrstellungen
beschossen werden
general egon ramms ist bei uns eher war
kommandeur des
streitkräfteführungskommando der nato
damit ranghöchster und einflussreichster
deutscher general bei der nato hätten
alle guten abend neu news sie als soldat
wenn sie das jetzt sehen die aktuelle
situation haben sie da können sie dann
rückschlüsse ziehen auf das was putin
vor hat auch seine taktik nein auf die
taktik kann man keine rückschlüsse sehen
wenn man den aufmarsch der truppenteile
sieht und das habe ich in dieser art und
weise auch nicht erwartet ist aber davon
auszugehen dass er seinen angriff auf
die gesamte ukraine ausdehnen wird und
er wird versuchen die gesamte ukraine in
die hand zu bekommen und wie will er
dann weiter verfahren also ist das was
wir da sehen auch schon teil einer
besatzungsarmee die dann eine ganze
bevölkerung unterjocht also wenn die
aussagen oder die informationen aus der
ukraine richtig sind nämlich dass die
bevölkerung hinter der jetzigen
regierung steht und zu einem
überwiegenden teil zwei drittel oder
mehr eine vorherrschaft der russen
ablehnen dann wird das sicherlich
hinterher kein spaziergang werden bei
denen man sofort der friede eintritt
sondern die bevölkerung wird sich in
teilen zur wehr setzen was hat denn die
ukraine dieser streitmacht die wir da
gerade gesehen haben entgegen zu stellen
ihre regulären streitkräfte etwa 200 bis
250 tausend soldaten
dazu kommt ein anteil reservisten der
offen sich zurzeit auch aufgrund der
weisungen von seelen ski weiter
verstärkt wird das problem was die
ukraine im augenblick hat ist dass sie
nicht genau weiß wo sie ihre abwehr
schwerpunkt bilden kann weil halt die
russische armee von allen seiten kommt
dann reden herr general über deutschland
da gab es heute auch wirklich in
bemerkenswerter äußerungen vom
inspekteur des heeres dem ranghöchsten
soldaten her dem generalinspekteur des
heeres der gesagt hat wir stehen hier
mehr oder weniger blank da ist das ein
offenbarungseid der bundeswehr oder ein
hilferuf
also ich glaube das ist vom genauen und
meister inspekteur des heeres beides
die bundeswehr das heer es engagiert in
verschiedenen aufgaben bei nato
verpflichtungen wir sind gerade erst
raus aus der sogenannten down phase bei
der sogenannten very high end taskforce
wir bereiten uns mit einer weiteren
brigade auf die nächste runde in 2023
vor wir sind beteiligt bei der northern
trust fonds zurzeit durch frankreich
geführt mit teilen der deutsch
französischen brigade und wir haben auch
weitere verpflichtungen so dass das was
die anoto verpflichtungen haben erfüllt
werden kann aber danach kommt nicht mehr
allzu viel und das ist der hilferuf der
inspekteur geschickt hat um das andere
es halt eben
man hat bestimmte absicht gehabt 2014
noch diese absichten nicht dürfen
danach kommt nicht mehr viel haben sie
gerade gesagt da muss ich noch mal
nachhaken was wäre denn dieses danach
fragen wir mal ganz konkret das ist will
ja keiner hoffen und steht aktuell
natürlich auch nicht zur debatte das
tatsächlich die bundeswehr dieses land
deutschland verteidigen muss wäre sie
dazu in der lage aktuell nein
eine klare antwort nein weil es fehlt an
neuers weil aufgrund der verkleinerung
der streitkräfte insgesamt insbesondere
den jahren nach 2010 11 des mangels an
geld welchem wir gehabt haben nach den
jahren 2010
ich sag das mal alle bevorratung im
bereich produktion ersatzteile
runtergefahren waren das bessert man
jetzt wieder auf aber wir haben sind
noch nicht einmal soweit dass die
teilstreitkräfte insbesondere das her
ich sag mal mit den organischen waffen
ausgerüstet ist die tatsächlich haben
müssen viel stoff über dem er auch mit
der politik dringend reden müssen auch
noch in dieser zeit noch general egon
ramms dankeschön dass sie bei uns waren
ja nicht nur der ranghöchste
heeressoldaten macht seiner wut luft und
seiner verärgerung auch von der
ehemaligen verteidigungs ministerin
annegret kramp karrenbauer kommt eine
bemerkenswerte generalabrechnung mit der
deutschen sicherheitspolitik und wohl
auch mit sich selbst wir haben
historisch versagt sagt sie wir merken
schon da gerät etwas in bewegung und
zwar ganz grundsätzlich
das brandenburger tor in berlin heute
den zweiten tag in folge in den farben
der ukraine der versuch solidarität zu
zeigen ein wahrzeichen ist schnell
erleuchtet wie sich dieses land auf die
veränderte situation einstellen muss da
geht die diskussion gerade erst los
reaktionen aus berlin von christiane
hübscher
ratlose augen rastlose krisentreffen
statements hilfloser entschlossenheit
von all den gibt es heute viel zu sehen
im regierungsviertel die nachrichten aus
der ukraine so furchtbar dass der
bundeskanzler sich am frühen abend im
fernsehen das volk richtet gerade zwei
flugstunden von berlin entfernt sitzen
moment familien in luftschutzkellern
frauen männer und kinder bangen um ihr
leben
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer bewaffnen
sich um ihre heimat gegen eine
invasionsarmee zu verteidigen
in diesen schweren stunden sind unsere
gedanken bei den tapferen bürgern und
bürgern der ukraine
diplomatie am ende alle gesprächskanäle
mit russland gekappt der auftritt von
aussenministerin berbalk am abend in der
zdf-sendung was nun macht klar so viel
enttäuschung so viel machtlosigkeit war
selten wir wurden eiskalt belogen der
kanzler wurde belogen ich bei vom
russischen außenminister die gesamte
internationale gemeinschaft aber sich
auf ein spiel einzulassen von jemand der
sich an keine regeln hält dann zu sagen
wir halten uns auch nicht mehr an regeln
das wäre aus meiner sicht der falsche
weg weil dann hätte putin gewonnen im
sicherheitskabinett in den fraktionen im
verteidigungsausschuss überall
verurteilung und verachtung für putin
parteiübergreifend dass wladimir putin
erzählt er fühlte sich von der ukraine
angegriffen oder es gäbe in der ukraine
ein völkermord ist schlichtweg eine lüge
dieser angriffskrieg von putin und der
russischen föderation ist auf das
schwerste zu verurteilen wir wissen
trotzdem dass wir im augenblick dagegen
relativ wenig unternehmen können der
angriff russlands auf die ukraine ist
auch durch nichts zu rechtfertigen
fordern auch russland auf die kampagnen
sofort zu unterlassen auch andere auf
die putin in deutschland noch bis
gestern zählen konnte geben sie heute
kritisch der krieg russland gegen die
ukraine ist zutiefst zu verurteilen
postet die linke wagenknecht spd
altkanzler und putin freund schröder
schreibt der krieg muss schnellstmöglich
beendet werden um gleich wieder zu
relativieren es gab viele fehler auf
beiden seiten tatsächlich löst dieser
schwarze tag auch selbstkritik in berlin
aus rückblickend muss man sagen wenn man
sich die schriften von putin aus dem
letzten sommer anschaut wenn man die
wortbeiträge zusammen schneidet das der
westen
opa deutschland zu naiv hätte
deutschland der ukraine doch auch waffen
liefern müssen manche außenexperte denkt
heute um es ist jetzt richtig weil nicht
mehr gesprochen wird dass auch
deutschland die ukraine durch lieferung
von militärischer ausrüstung unterstützt
sowieso kenne jede waffe aus deutschland
für die ukraine zu spät aber die
diskussion ist da und wird die neue
ampel regierung nach beschäftigen
ja das wirkt wie eine zeitenwende auch
für die deutsche sicherheitspolitik
theo lässt sich schon ermessen was das
konkret bedeuten wird ein konkret nicht
aber es ist etwas in bewegung geraten
mit dem heutigen tag hat eine art von
neubewertungen begonnen denn die
bisherige politik der zurückhaltung und
der friedensdividende ist offensichtlich
nicht ausreichend um sich gegen jemanden
der alle regeln berichtete angreifer wie
putins überhaupt vizekanzler habeck
spricht von naivität wir haben es gerade
gehört im umgang mit putin und wir leben
auch das erfahrene außenpolitiker wie
norbert röttgen der sich lange gegen
waffenlieferungen die ukraine gewährt
hat jetzt dafür ist also verbündete
staaten dürften möglicherweise künftig
auf stärkere hilfe offen selbst wenn sie
nicht zur nato gehören wir sind in einer
anderen welt aufgewacht hat die aus
ministerin gesagt und das könnte sich
auch auf die eigene politik beziehen und
dann theo gibt's heute die mitteilung
des verteidigungsministeriums das
bundesministerium der verteidigung löst
zitat nationale alarm maßnahmen aus was
steckt dahinter
dahinter steckt die aufforderung der
nato an ihre mitglieder also an die
staaten sogenannte krisen
reaktionsmechanismus
ist ein nato katalog für den krisenfall
und in der folge hat dann das deutsche
verteidigungsministerium in die
nationalen al ahmars namen ausgelöst
damit müssen jetzt knapp 14.000
bundeswehr soldaten innerhalb von
kürzester zeit mit der nato
eingreiftruppe verlegbare sein also wenn
sie in den nächsten tagen staus durch
große militärkonvois auf den straßen
erleben dann sind es genau diese truppen
die sich bereit machen tatsächlich etwas
zu spüren und bereits jetzt theo koll
ganz herzlichen dank am späten
nachmittag ist russlands präsident dann
noch mal vor die fernsehkameras getreten
besonders beeindruckt von der reaktion
des westens zeigt er sich nicht
russland ist noch immer teil der und da
wir noch teil der globalen wirtschaft
sind werden wir das system zudem wir
gehören ja nicht beschädigt
ich denke unsere partner müssen das
verstehen und aufhören uns aus dem
system zu drängen
trotz allem erlegen sie uns sanktionen
auch aus politischen gründen
der bundesfinanzminister ist bei uns gut
nahm christian lindner
hallo guten abend bislang haben die
sanktionen wird die mir putin nicht
abgeschreckt das ist spätestens seit der
vergangenen nacht ganz klar und er wirkt
auch nicht als würden ihn kommende
sanktionen schrecken was haben sie denn
was hat der westen denn überhaupt in der
hand
wir haben sehr konsequente und auch für
das russische volk spürbare sanktionen
vorbereitet und die werden jetzt in
kraft gesetzt es gibt einen bann für
russische banken es gibt
exportbeschränkungen beispielsweise bei
technologie gütern es gibt
beschränkungen die individuell sich
richten gegen träger der herrschaft von
vladimir putin das mag heute am tag
haben putin vielleicht nicht
beeindrucken weil er sicher zum krieg
entschlossen hat aber die auswirkungen
auf das russische volk und die russische
wirtschaft die werden spürbar sein wenn
harte sanktionen wirklich hart sein
sollen dann treffen sie aber eben nicht
nur russland sondern auch deutschland
ist unser land darauf ausreichend
vorbereitet
die bundesregierung tut alles in ihrer
macht stehende um die negativen
auswirkungen auf unser land zu begrenzen
dass in sicherheitsfragen denke an den
bereich von cyber sicherheit und
desinformationskampagne und das ist auch
die frage der wirtschaftlichen folgen
also die energiesicherheit die
versorgungssicherheit zum einen und zum
anderen auch die finanzstabilität wir
sind darauf vorbereitet
wir haben maßnahmen bereits gestern mit
blick auf die inflationsentwicklung im
koalitionsausschuss beschlossen
bei den energiepreisen zum beispiel und
weitere maßnahmen sind denkbar wir
werden dafür sorgen dass aus dem
schlimmen krieg diesen albtraum von
krieg in europa nicht auch noch eine
wirtschaftskrise in europa wird linda
haben wir historisch versagt wie heute
die frühere verteidigungsministerin sagt
wir haben gewiss die bundeswehr
vernachlässigt wir haben unsere
streitkräfte und darauf hat sich ja auch
die frühere
verteidigungsministerin bezogen wir
haben unsere streitkräfte nicht in der
weise er tüchtig und ausgestattet wie
das möglich ist wie konnte das passieren
der ausgesetzt das muslim regiert werden
wir haben eine verzögerung in der in der
leitung nachhinein anderes passieren aus
ihrer sicht
es gab eine friedensdividende das heißt
wir hatten nach dem ende des kalten
krieges das gefühl das brauchen wir
nicht mehr andere übernehmen die lasten
etwa die vereinigten staaten und
deutschland hat sie auch anderen fragen
wie beispielsweise der entwicklung des
sozialstaates gewidmet und darüber ist
eine der wichtigsten staatlichen
aufgaben die äußere sicherheit zu
garantieren
in den hintergrund geraten über jahre
das muss jetzt wenn es nach mir geht
korrigiert werden wir müssen die
bundeswehr stärken und das bedeutet auch
investitionen in die äußere sicherheit
in die bündnisverteidigung innerhalb der
nato
dann hat so ein bisschen den eindruck in
deutschland unsere autobahnen sind
marode bei der digitalisierung hinken
wir hinterher jetzt erfahren wir gerade
sehr schmerzhaft dass auch in der
verteidigung sehr sehr viel gespart
wurde sie haben gesagt sie wollen das
jetzt ändern das wird ja sehr sehr teuer
und kommt natürlich zusätzlich zu all
den anderen ausgaben die sie ohnehin
schon die wir alle als steuerzahlerinnen
und steuerzahler ohnehin schon schultern
müssen können sie das beziffern haben
sie da überhaupt noch einen überblick
als finanzminister aktuell bei all dem
was in der welt passiert
ja den überblick haben wir und ja die
herausforderungen sind groß den wir uns
gemeinsam stellen müssen ich weiß
deshalb dass es eine grundvoraussetzung
gibt dass wir das alles leisten können
und das ist dass wir unsere
wirtschaftliche wettbewerbsfähigkeit
unsere wirtschaftliche substanz erhalten
nach der pandemie müssen wir dafür
sorgen dass mittelstand handwerk und
industrie an frühere erfolge anknüpfen
können dass er es gibt dem staat mittel
und zum anderen werden wir klare
prioritäten herr sievers vornehmen
müssen nicht alles was wünscht ist und
ich habe auch wünsche was der staat noch
tun kann nicht alles was wünscht es ist
sofort finanzierbar jetzt geht es um
prioritäten und eine der prioritäten ist
die äußere sicherheit die ansage des
bundesfinanzministers heute abend
christian lindner danke fürs gespräch
bitte
geben sie dem frieden eine chance das
war heute nach der appell des uno
generalsekretärs
in moskau hat die niemand gehört der
russische präsident gab den
angriffsbefehl exakt während einer
krisensitzung des uno-sicherheitsrats
perfides timing die internationale
staatengemeinschaft
düpiert die charta der vereinten
nationen gibt den sicherheitsrat
versammelten eine klare aufgabe den
weltfrieden waren johannes hano zeigt
die traurige realität bilder und töne
eines krisentreffens das wohl niemand
der dabei war vergessen wird
schon am frühen mittwochabend hatten die
vereinten nationen hinweise darauf dass
russland kurz vor einem einmarsch in die
ukraine steht um 21.30 dann
dringlichkeitssitzung des
un-sicherheitsrates letzte versuche
russland von einem krieg abzuhalten
von ganzem herzen bitte ich sie
präsident putin stoppen sie ihre truppen
vor einem angriff auf die ukraine geben
sie dem frieden eine chance zu viele
menschen sind schon gestorben
wir sind heute und hier im russland
aufzufordern einen krieg abzuwenden
seit monaten hält präsident putin eine
pistole an den kopf der ukraine
jetzt hat gut in den fingern
es ist jetzt etwa 22.30 seit einer
stunde bringt das wichtigste gremium der
vereinten nationen um eine friedliche
lösung da verkündet er botschafter
russlands mitten in der sitzung die
entscheidung seines präsidenten
der russische präsident putin hat mit
mir gesprochen er hat die entscheidung
für eine militär operation im donbass
getroffen wir kennen nicht alle details
aber wir wollen sie darüber informieren
das ist nicht unser plan ist die ukraine
zu gesetzen
die mitglieder des sicherheitsrates
fassungslos ob der offensichtlich
gezielten demütigung der vereinten
nationen und der weltordnung die sie
repräsentieren
in dem moment so wie sie zusammen zinsen
und uns um frieden bemühen verkündet
putin die botschaft des krieges in
vollkommener verachtung für die
verantwortung des sicherheitsrates die
welt wird russland zur verantwortung
ziehen
diese entscheidung just zu dem zeitpunkt
wo wir uns im sicherheitsrat treffen
zeigt russlands verachtung für das
internationale recht und die vereinten
nationen
emotional fast verzweifelt wendet sich
der ukrainische botschafter direkt an
seinen russischen kollegen
ihr präsident hat der ukraine den krieg
erklärt
die vordere den russischen botschafter
auf jetzt hier vor der welt zu erklären
dass sind diesen moment keine
ukrainischen städte bombardiert werden
dass ihre truppen nicht einmarschieren
auf unser territorium
der russische botschafter aber schweigt
die antwort europas heißt sanktionen es
soll das schärfste und stärkste paket
sein das die eu jemals geschnürt hat das
ist zunächst mal nicht mehr als eine
ankündigung des außenbeauftragten
entscheidend werden die details heute
abend treffen sich die mächtigen der eu
in brüssel und zwar persönlich florian a
auch krawatten können zeichen setzen der
slowenische premier hat sich für den
abend eine in den farben der ukraine
ausgesucht es ist ein zeichen wie so
viele an diesem abend aber wenn es nach
janez jansa geht sollte es nicht bei
symbolen bleiben sowie support wir
fordern die schärfsten sanktionen gegen
russland die möglich sind wir reden
jedoch nicht über wirtschaftsdaten ob
die installation nun fünf oder sechs
prozent beträgt wir sprechen hier über
ein menschenleben ersten world of your
life wie scharf reagiert die eu was
lässt sie sich ihre reaktion auf
russlands krieg osten ist die frage die
den tag bestimmt schon früh um 5 uhr 55
setzt die kommissionspräsidentin den
ersten tweet ab und damit den ton man
werde russland zur rechenschaft ziehen
was ursula von der leyen später an
diesem tag mehrfach ähnlich begründet
die setzt es geht hier nicht nur um den
don was sie nicht nur um die ukraine es
geht hier um die stabilität von europa
und der welt um unsere friedensordnung
nach
der russischen anerkennung der
separatisten gebiet hatte europa
sanktionen gegen russische politiker
verhängt jetzt will man die russische
wirtschaft treffen etwa mit export
verboten bei high tech produkten
einschränkungen bei der vergabe von visa
oder dem einfrieren von russischen
vermögen in der eu reicht das
wieder nied wir brauchen keine großen
erklärungen heute abend wir brauchen
schnelle entscheidungen
wir brauchen auch keine sanktionen die
balance wir brauchen sanktionen die
weißen
ob er das meint was der ukrainische
außenminister kurz vorher getwittert hat
die metropole beschreibt ganz
undiplomatisch in großbuchstaben
schließt russland aus swift aus trifft
hier die zentrale vor den toren brüssels
ist das zahlungssystem über das banken
weltweit überweisungen abwickeln ein
ausschluss russlands wäre die härteste
waffe des westens aber eine die auch
europas banken treffen würde die
milliarden an krediten abschreiben
müssten und so bremst offenbar auch
deutschland gefragt danach will olaf
scholz die maßnahme zumindest lieber auf
behalten für eine situation wo das
notwendig ist auch noch andere dinge zu
tun welche situation er meint sagt
scholz nicht in der gipfelerklärung vor
einer halben stunde verabschiedet kein
wort zu swift dafür wird das gebäude der
eu kommission an diesem abend auch in
den farben der ukraine angeleuchtet
bringen wir zu komponenten mit dazu in
brüssel in washington zunächst anne
gellinek zu dir nach brüssel gibt es
etwas was die eu zuversichtlich macht
dass jemand der sich von der androhung
der sanktionen nicht abschrecken lassen
diese sanktionen jetzt ernst nimmt
zuversichtlich ist vielleicht der
falsche ausdruck die staats und
regierungschefs glauben natürlich nicht
dass wladimir putin jetzt die waffen
niederlegt angesichts einer europäischen
sanktionsliste die eu zielt er auf das
umfeld von wladimir putin und auf die
langstrecke die sanktionen über die hier
heute abend geredet wird sollen nicht
die russische bevölkerung treffen
sondern sie sollen die leute treffen die
zum umfeld von wladimir putin gehören
milliardäre bankiers gas magnaten alles
leute die in der zeit von putin sehr
sehr viel geld verdient haben deren
leben soll unbequemer werden und dazu
führen dass soll dazu führen dass auch
sie unbequeme fragen an wladimir putin
stellen da die medien selbst steht
übrigens nicht auf der sanktionsliste
man will sich auch in dieser phase noch
ein letztes kleines fensterchen des
dialogs offenheit und dann gehen wir
weiter darüber nach washington zu el
mati wissen wie konkret sehen die
sanktionen des präsidenten denn jetzt
aus
ja es gibt sanktionen gegen die größten
banken russlands die putin für den
erhalt der russischen wirtschaft braucht
die bankenchefs und ihre familien stehen
auf der sanktionsliste und eben
tatsächlich verbote von exporten namen
high tech industrie in russland rüstung
und luft und raumfahrt beispielsweise
diese firmen werden getroffen die haben
ein geld oder kapital zur verfügung von
zweieinhalb billionen dollar dass sie
jetzt eben nicht mehr frei bewegen
können und der us-amerikanische
präsident sagte putin wird am ende
russland geschwächt und den rest der
welt gestärkt haben und dann fuhr er mit
folgenden worten ford
demokratie menschenwürde diese kräfte
sind viel stärker als jene der angst und
unterdrückung
sie können nicht ausgelöscht werden von
tyrannen wie putin und seinen armeen
ikea sie können nicht aus den herzen und
hoffnungen der menschen entfernt werden
durch gewalt und einschüchterung sie
bestehen wettbewerb zwischen demokratie
und autokratie zwischen souveränität und
unterdrückung täuschen sie sich nicht
freiheit wird sich durchsetzen
[Musik]
oder präsident hatte kaum ausgesprochen
da wurde hier dann schon heftig
diskutiert ob diese sanktionen wirklich
ausreichend sind herzlichen dank für
diese informationen nach washington und
natürlich auch nach brüssel ja eines ist
an diesem düsteren tag ganz klar
geworden nämlich was von all den
beschwichtigungen zu halten ist die in
den letzten wochen vom russischen
präsidenten kamen wie sehr man sich
darauf verlassen kann wenn wladimir
putin sagt sein monatelanger
truppenaufmarsch sei temporär und nichts
als ein manöver christian von rechenberg
dezember 20 21 pressekonferenz mit putin
zu dieser zeit hat er bereits knapp 100
tausend russische soldaten in die nähe
der grenze zur ukraine geschickt ständig
hören der krieg krieg krieg man kann das
gefühl bekommen dass die ukraine eine
dritte militär operation vorbereitet und
uns warnt man mischen sie sich da nicht
ein
fünfzehnter februar antritt besuch von
bundeskanzler scholz in moskau in der
gemeinsamen pressekonferenz sagt putin
im hinblick darauf ob ihr krieg in
europa wollen oder nicht
natürlich nicht deshalb legen wir
vorschläge für einen verhandlungsprozess
auf den tisch diese hatten das ziel das
wir uns auch die gewährleistung gleicher
sicherheit für alle also auch für unser
land einigen
18 februar treffen lukaschenko und putin
beide halten nach der ukraine ein
gewaltiges manöver ab angeblich so putin
zogen die truppen in wenigen tagen
wieder ab außerdem möchte ich
ausdrücklich betonen dass diese manöver
einen rein defensiven charakter haben
und niemanden bedrohen
ja und dann kam der heutige tag für das
große bild der welt an diesem tag ist
stefan meister jetzt bei uns russland
experte der deutschen gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik schön dass sie da
sind genannter meister guten abend sind
sie denn jetzt schlauer was wladimir
putin wirklich will und wie weit er
gehen würde
ich glaube platini putin will letztlich
zwei dinge seien ukraine politik war
gescheitert und er möchte die ukraine
unter kontrolle bringen mehr ist hier
auf einer historischen mission
sieht die ukraine als teil russlands und
gleichzeitig kämpfte und in der ukraine
gegen die amerikaner also er sieht
sozusagen die ukraine als als als unter
kontrolle der usa möchte die usa aus
europa drängen und und letztlich eine
neue europäische sicherheits- oder
aushandeln und dafür kämpft er letztlich
in der ukraine eine neue europäische
sicherheitsnorm hat denn der westen dem
wirklich etwas entgegenzusetzen
ich glaube der westen ist letztlich
darauf weder mental noch militärisch
vorbereitet
es fehlt jegliche bereitschaft hier auch
adäquat zu reagieren
und keiner hat mir diesen krieg
gerechnet also wir haben vielleicht alle
auch gehofft dass er nicht stattfinden
wird aber letztlich sind wir ja wir sind
wir sind letztlich nicht wirklich darauf
vorbereitet
wie konnte das aus ihrer sicht passieren
dass wir über all die jahre den mann im
kreml offenbar so komplett falsch
eingeschätzt haben
das ist ich denke wenn sie sich die
deutsche politik anschauen haben wir zum
teil auch und eine art
realitätsverweigerung gelitten ich meine
wir haben 2014 eine addition der krim
gehabten krieg im dornbusch und wir
wussten so zu sagen dass putin bereit
ist krieg zu führen und auch krieg teil
seiner außenpolitik ist trotzdem haben
wir weiter gas speicher verkauft
trotzdem haben wir gas
lieferungen aus der ukraine erhöht und
wir haben letztlich und
sicherheitspolitisch auf diese neue welt
die im prinzip damit schon eingeläutet
worden ist nicht vorbereitet herr
meister ich muss sie noch nach einem
einem satz von wladimir putin fragen mit
dem wir diese sendung heute abend
begonnen haben und der einem nicht mehr
aus dem kopf geht er hat gesagt wer
versucht uns zu stoppen oder unser land
bedroht der sollte wissen dass unsere
antwort schnell sein wird und jetzt
kommt's konsequenzen hat solche die es
in der geschichte noch nie gab was lesen
sie aus diesen worten
ich lese daraus dass putin letztlich zu
einem bereit ist dass ihnen keine
sanktionen davon abhalten werden die
ukraine also in der ukraine an zu halten
oder zu stoppen und ich lese auch daraus
dass selbst die nukleare option mit auf
dem tisch liegt also dass auch
nuklearwaffen teil der russischen
militär strategie sind und ja russland
ist eine militärmacht also sehr sehr
gefährlich die die nukleare option
dann müssen noch mal kurz drüber reden
denn das macht ja jedem wirklich angst
ist das dann als abschreckung gemeint
oder wie man sie dass ich meinen
abschreckung also das einfach teil
sozusagen diese dieses angriffs auf die
ukraine dieses krieges in der ukraine
bei einem möglichen rückschlag oder bei
einer möglichen gegenattacke oder auch
bei einem stärkeren involvieren der nato
der usa lausanne mit mit mit möglichen
atom schlägen droht das ist vorstellbar
dass ist das was an tatsächlich die
option zieht so weit würde ich nicht
gehen also sollen jetzt hier nicht in
panik verfallen aber es ist teil dieser
strategie sozusagen auch abzuschrecken
über atomwaffen ganz kurz noch einmal
gibt es noch irgendjemanden auf dieser
welt auf den putin hören würde die
chinesen vielleicht
ich glaube nicht dass putin sich wie
schon das von irgendjemandem abhalten
wird also eher wie weit er ist auf einer
historischen mission er will die ukraine
zurück haben er will in die
geschichtsbücher eingehen und ich sehe
was jetzt die ukraine betrifft im moment
nicht das dass man ihn aufhalten kann
der langjährige russland experte stefan
meister deutsche gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik herzlichen dank dass
sie heute bei uns waren im heute journal
ich sehr gerne
es gibt
gewinn lag aber sehr viele die verlieren
so ist es wenn krieg ist in der
wirtschaft und an der börse eben auch
kurse fallen preise steigen insbesondere
für rohstoffe und energie
valerie haller guten abend ein
dramatischer tag auch für die
finanzmärkte ja also zum beispiel der
russen russische aktienindex hat
zwischenzeitlich auf ein schlag über 50
prozent verloren der rubel ist
eingebrochen aber natürlich nicht nur in
moskau weltweit rauschen die aktienkurse
nach unten viele investoren schichten um
den anlagen wie gold und deutsche
staatsanleihen die gelten in
krisenzeiten eben als sichere häfen der
dax ist schon seit tagen unter druck
fällt heute noch mal tief verliert 4
prozent ja und gleichzeitig springt der
ölpreis um 9% nach oben auch der
erdgaspreis an der terminbörse steigt
zwischenzeitlich um 40 prozent das war
zu erwarten dass die energiepreise nach
oben schnellen russland ist ja nicht nur
gas und öl lieferant sondern auch einer
der weltweiten anbieter von aluminium
und anderen industriemetallen die in
ganz ganz vielen produkten stecken die
preise dürften also erstmal weiter nach
oben gehen das bedeutet nichts gutes für
die jetzt schon hohe inflation in europa
ja viele sorgen also auch auf diesem
gebiet valerie vielen dank
ein tag der in die geschichte eingehen
wird europa vor einer neuen zeit dazu
jetzt der kommentar von
zdf-chefredakteur peter frey
an einem beklemmenden tag für europa ist
kiew unter beschuss putin will eine
epoche beenden die 1990 hoffnungsvoll
begonnen hatte es ist eine invasion ein
bruch des völkerrechts ein krieg den die
ukraine nichts entgegenzusetzen hat
putin greift nach der ganzen ukraine und
droht wer ihr zur hilfe kommt der muss
mit einem noch größeren krieg rechnen
der herrscher im kreml ist einsam und
gefährlich der heutige tag markiert den
zusammenbruch der deutschen
russlandpolitik es war auch angela
merkel die 2008 der ukraine den
nato-beitritt verweigerte um putin zu
besänftigen
das galt damals als friedens tat heute
erweist es sich als verhängnisvoll für
die ukraine mit putin reden mit putin
geschäfte machen auch das wandel durch
handel konzept für das insbesondere die
spd steht ist gescheitert dass ein
altkanzler bis zuletzt als putins
cheflobbyist agitierte ist beschämend
zwei jahrzehnte wurde es versäumt
alternativen für die deutsche
energieversorgung zu entwickeln das
immer fließende gas aus sibirien
verbunden mit immer weniger bereitschaft
unsere sicherheit militärisch zu
schützen das war eine fatale mischung
jetzt wird der preis fällig wir
verbraucher werden ihn an den
tankstellen und an der gasrechnung
ablesen können und die bundesregierung
wird von putin gezwungen eigene ziele
hinten anzustellen um die bundeswehr für
ein neues zeitalter der konfrontation zu
ertüchtigen
1990 war nicht das ende der geschichte
32 jahre nach dem mauerfall droht ein
neuer kalter krieg mit diktatoren kann
es keine partnerschaft geben wir müssen
geschlossener denn je dafür kämpfen dass
die demokratie stärker bleibt
peter frey kommentierte jetzt weitere
nachrichten von heute und die hat hahn
einblick wegen der explodierenden
energiepreise hat die ampel koalition am
mittwoch ein milliardenschweres
entlastungspaket für bürgerinnen und
bürger beschlossen heute nun folgte die
kritik verbände verbraucherschützer und
opposition fordern nachbesserungen
sozialverbände kritisieren die maßnahmen
als zu niedrig und sozial ungerecht und
auch die linke bemängelt dass gerade
arme menschen nicht genug entlastet
würden von cdu und csu kommt die
forderung nach weitergehenden
steuersenkungen
gestern abend hatten sich die
koalitionsspitzen unter anderem auf eine
schnellere abschaffung der
ökostrom-umlage geeinigt zudem ist eine
anhebung der pendlerpauschale geplant
und sonderzahlungen für bedürftige und
für von armut betroffene kinder
auf dem deutschen arbeitsmarkt gibt es
so viele freie stellen wie noch nie
zuvor das geht aus einer untersuchung
des instituts für arbeitsmarkt und
berufsforschung hervor im vierten
quartal
2021 gab es insgesamt
1,69 millionen offene stellen das sei
der höchste wert seit beginn der messung
und ist ein sattes plus von 43 prozent
im vergleich zum vorjahresquartal
da waren es 500 7000 weniger die meisten
freien stellen seien in kleineren oder
bei kleinstbetrieben zu besetzen
in großbritannien sind heute die letzten
staatlichen corona regeln weggefallen in
deutschland sind wir dagegen noch nicht
so weit es wird schrittweise geöffnet
und wie die bürgerinnen und bürger das
finden zeigt als aktuelle zdf
politbarometer
55 prozent der befragten halten die
vorgesehenen lockerungen für gerade
richtig
25 prozent gehen den gehen sie zu weit
und 16 prozent hätten sich mehr
gewünscht weitere ergebnisse des
politbarometers finden sie online auf
zdf heute
der krieg in der ukraine hat
konsequenzen für den kölner karneval
das kölner festkomitee hat das
rosenmontags fest abgesagt stattdessen
soll es eine friedensdemonstration in
der kölner innenstadt geben
verschiedenen plätzen sollen dann auch
die persiflage wagen stehen
auch die fußball welt reagiert auf die
angriffe das finalspiel der champions
league sollen nicht wie geplant in sankt
petersburg stattfinden morgen wird sich
die uefa offiziell dazu äußern
hier fliegt näher an uns hier in
deutschland dran als manche wochen in
sonnen ziele die wir wie
selbstverständlich im billigflieger
ansteuern für fast 150000 menschen bei
uns hier ist kiew noch mal näher weil
sie aus der ukraine stammen weil sie
eltern dort haben oder kinder weil sie
trost suchen heute und rat weil sie
bangen und weinen simon pfanzelt
berichtet aus bayern
sie haben hier schon so oft für den
frieden in der ukraine gebetet heute tun
sie das mit einer ganz neuen
dringlichkeit
in münchen hat der pfarrer der
ukrainischen katholischen gemeinde am
abend zum gottesdienst geladen beten was
sollen sie sonst auch tun wenn verwandte
und freunde vom krieg berichten das ist
eine große verunsicherung dass es
in angst beim fliegen die flugzeuge
militärflugzeuge überall hört man die
bomben also das ist ein schreckliches
szenario als sie heute aufgewacht sind
war der krieg da jetzt fühlen sie trauer
und unsicherheit und wut auf putin was
verteidigte er ergreift uns an eindeutig
was verteidigt der einzigste was ich
machen kann das ist ja jetzt beten und
einfach meine solidarität zu zeigen
und um ihr leider nicht
was tun wenn die alte heimat brennt die
einen suchen hoffnung im gebet andere
hoffen auf die kraft der straße in
nürnberg protestieren am abend tausende
für einen frieden den es nicht mehr gibt
fünf wochen hat mich mein ganz ganz gut
auf freund angerufen und gemeint wir
haben krieg unsere familie schläft man
bomben bahnhöfe brennen flughäfen sind
kaputt es gibt kein wasser tatsächlich
in krankenhäusern und dass seine
humanitäre katastrophe es gibt wenig
hoffnung in der ukrainischen gemeinde in
deutschland und bei vielen auch wenig
vertrauen in die reaktion des westens
der sanktionen kommen jetzt wie oft
kommen sie zu spät dass
man sich den militärs da steht schon in
unseren städten und
schießen und es wird getötet und
gemordet es sind ihre freunde ihre
verwandten die jetzt im krieg leben und
keiner weiß heute wie das alles endet
[Musik]
es ist jetzt eine halbe stunde vor
mitternacht in kiew
dort und an anderen orten in diesem
riesigen land sitzen menschen jetzt den
todesangst im bunker oder dort wo gerade
noch u bahn stationen waren suchen nach
vermissten angehörigen
planen ihre flucht ohne zu wissen wohin
und fragen sich was als nächstes kommt
es ist erst tag eins des krieges gegen
die ukraine tag 1 einer neuen
herausforderung für europa für uns alle
danke dass sie diesen denkwürdigen
nachrichten tag diesen 24 februar
2022 mit uns erlebt haben und gegen 0.10
meldet sich hier nazan götter mir mit
einem verlängerten heute-journal update
und den neuesten entwicklungen in der
ukraine in allen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
stammte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die kaltfront die derzeit über
uns liegt verlagert sich über nacht
relativ rasch nach osten und südosten
dabei sind schauer und gewitter und auch
sturmböen und mit der kühlen luft die
morgen im tagesverlauf einfließt gibt es
weitere schauer und gewitter durchaus
auch mal schnee bis ins flachland
das kann auch in dieser kommende nacht
schon sein vor allem über den
mittelgebirgen hier teilweise glätte
eben durch schnee auf den fahrbahnen
aber auch überfrierende nässe sonst gibt
es auch gewitter ganz im norden auch
teilweise sturmböen um west temperaturen
sinken dabei auf 0 bis minus 3 grad am
mildesten noch gerade an der nordsee mit
plus 3 grad morgen im tagesverlauf also
weitere schauer und gewitter und auch
mal schneeflocken bis nach ganz unten
zumindest vorübergehend zwischendurch
sonnenschein der winter ist auch vor
allem der nähe von gewittern kräftig
teilweise stürmisch bis auch mit
sturmböen temperaturen dazu höchste
werte von 3 grad an den alpen 10 im
südwesten aber häufig temperaturen unter
der zehn grad marke am samstag gibt es
letzte schauer mit regen und durchaus
schnee in den höheren lagen sowie am
alpenrand aber nach westen viel
sonnenschein bei zwei bis neun grad und
so sieht es auch in den nächsten tagen
aus mit viel sonne geht es am sonntag
und montag weiter am montag dann mit
zwölf grad ein wenig milder und damit
ein schöner abend